the housing secretary robert generic is
with us i want to talk about manchester
in just a second if we may mr general
good morning but first
freedom day that's what everybody is
talking about
looking at this morning's papers
complete confusion
uh mr gove saying if he was a betting
man the restrictions would be relaxed
was she soon as
saying potentially that he'd accept a
four-week delay the backbencher powerful
backbencher steve baker saying
don't you dare what's your view well i'm
not going to comment on the discussions
that are happening within the cabinet
but
the prime minister is reviewing the data
and more data is coming in
which is very important we created this
five-week period between the stages of
the roadmap and that has actually proved
invaluable
on this occasion because it's a finely
balanced decision
and we need to see that data of cases
which are clearly rising
but the link to hospitalizations and
ultimately to death so
the pm is reviewing that ahead of the
decision point which is going to be the
14th
of june at that point of course he'll
let everybody know what the ultimate
decision is but you're a secretary of
state you have a view what's your view
well i'm not going to give my view the
obviously those views are made privately
within the cabinet but what i do think
is important is that we don't
throw away the gains that we've made so
we're going to take a a cautious
approach
but if we can proceed with that
reopening on the 24th
of course all of us would love to see
that for in our own lives and the
livelihoods that depend on that further
reopening
yeah something you will have a view on
andrew lloyd webber on the front page of
the telegraph today i'm sure you've seen
it he's
launching his multi-million pound
production of cinderella on the west end
stage
he says that is going to happen come
hell or high water no matter what you
decide about the 21st of june
and if you want the police can come and
arrest us if the restrictions aren't
lifted
should the police arrest him well i
completely empathize with andrew lloyd
webber and
more importantly all of the people who
work in the cultural sector people who
work in
theaters and and other venues for whom
it's been a very difficult year
amongst other parts of the economy we
want to get them open
we are doing pilots we want to get those
theaters open so great new productions
like cinderella can open i know that
people are desperate to go to them
tickets
are selling fast for all those
productions because people have been
away too long
but you just got a few more days to wait
until the judgment that the prime
minister's going to make
on the base of the data and in answer to
my question should he be arrested if he
breaks those rules well look
i i'm sure that andrew lloyd webber's
comments are made um
um in uh the heat of the moment what
what he's very serious he well he i'm
sure he feels this very strongly but
look we all have to
do our best to abide by to be arrested
he says come and arrest us
well we all have to abide by the rules
um
yes isn't it um i'm not going to get
into uh speculation about that but we
want to get those theaters back open
obviously
as quickly as we can to support people
like andrew lloyd webber so that we can
all enjoy brilliant productions in the
west end once again what about those 50
000 weddings that are
at risk if we are postponed for another
month what would you say to uh
prospective
bride and grooms at the moment well
weddings can go ahead
right now but with a maximum of 30. 30
guests and
people ranging sorry i appreciate that
that's very tough and i would like to to
see the number of people
attending weddings increase we're giving
that careful thought
that will be one of the topics that the
pm will address on the 14th of june so
again
people who are looking forward to those
but don't have very long to wait for
them so what's your advice to those
people who are you know hovering up with
the red marker pen over who
can no longer be invited potentially
well we've always said
that the road map is subject to review
of the data
that is what is happening right now so
whether it's weddings or international
travel or any of these other
important topics you always have to wait
until
the judgment is made on the basis of the
data at the decision point so
i i i wouldn't make plans until you've
heard from the pm if that's important to
you but weddings can go ahead
right now but just with the maximum of
30 guests what can go ahead in
manchester
and lancashire right now greater
manchester i should say uh meet outdoors
and minimize
travel is what people are being told
what does minimising travel actually
mean what's that look like well these
are guidelines
so we're offering some extra advice to
people who live in that area
this isn't the law but you can clearly
see that cases are rising
in manchester and so we're asking people
to use their personal judgment
personal responsibility in order to help
us
to bring down the number of cases and
we've done that in bolton
very successfully a huge effort by
people there
great work by the local council and the
nhs
so we want to replicate that model in
greater manchester clearly
although bolton is the biggest town in
england greater manchester is a much
larger
connervation and so it's going to be a
big job but we're going to give all the
support we possibly can through the nhs
to surge
testing through armed forces support as
well
to try to do that and people can play
their part by
limiting their contact with other people
taking that guidance seriously
and above all by going out and getting
vaccinated
having your second jab if you haven't
already if you're a younger person now
who's eligible going and get vaccinated
because we're really in a
in a race between the vaccine roll out
and the virus and in those places in
particular where cases are rising
you need to go and get vaccinated as
quickly as you can i hope you're not
saying i'm old because i've had both
vaccines
not at all okay please check it but it
is great news okay
that we've got this huge surge in young
people going to get vaccinated
so we've seen half a million young
people registering booking their
appointments
just within a matter of days since matt
hancock the health secretary announced
that
uh younger age groups are now eligible
and lots of those young people want to
go
on holiday abroad i am confused what the
what the guidance is from the government
on foreign holidays what is it
well let me be clear you shouldn't be
booking holidays
to countries that are currently on
either the amber list
or the red list you can go to the
admittedly relatively small number of
countries on
the green list even there be aware that
this isn't a normal summer
for holidays we are reviewing that list
every three weeks and so
i would advise people to look for travel
operators who can offer flexibility
will be able to offer rescheduling or
repayments if something changes
we would like to open up that green list
to more countries
but we've obviously got to do so
cautiously so we're reviewing
cases and hospitalizations in those
countries and also
looking at whether those countries have
the level of genomic sequencing that's
required to give us comfort
that there aren't new variants that
might be of concern to us
and if we can open up more we obviously
will do because we'd love to give people
more opportunities to travel george used
us yesterday sat there
front page of the times now as a result
saying we should holiday at home this
year
well i think a lot of people are coming
to the conclusion
perfectly understandably that this isn't
a normal summer opportunities for
international travel are going to be
more limited
and so why not enjoy everything that
this country has to offer
this summer that's probably the decision
that i'm going to make many other people
will be doing the same but
we would like to offer people the
opportunity to go to more of those
greenless countries
but that's very dependent on what's
happening there and
we can't control the vaccination rollout
in those countries
we obviously can't control the spread of
new variants and we have to do
everything that we can
to protect all that we're achieving here
domestically so
on balance the correct decision is to
holiday at home this year and that's
what you're going to do
no i'm not saying that i'm saying that
it's a matter for individuals
we've set up a framework which i hope is
clear which is that you should really
only be booking well you should only be
booking
holidays to countries that are currently
on the green list and
even there you should be aware that
they're subject to review every three
weeks
so you have to try to um either exercise
caution when you do that or
try to get holidays that you can get
rescheduled or refunded should something
change so for many people they may
conclude that the safest option
is to enjoy what this country has to
offer this summer and that's the right
thing to do
well it's not a question of what's right
or wrong i'm trying to give the best
possible advice to people
people will make their own judgments you
can choose to book a holiday
to a country that's on the green list
but there's always a degree of risk
involved in that because those countries
are reviewed as we've seen
with portugal and things can move quite
quickly is the prime minister holidaying
abroad this year
i don't know i haven't asked him but i
know that he's going to cornwall
i know that he's going to well he's got
a lot of other things on his mind i know
that he's going to cornwall today
to carver's bait which is a place that
he knows well and loves
ready to welcome the leaders of the g7
to the united kingdom which brings us on
to
uh brexit and sausage wars as it's being
described
lord frost is the brexit secretary he's
meeting his counterpart today and the pm
is meeting president biden tomorrow i
think
a uk us trade deal we're led to believe
relies on the outcome of this
sausage wars um what an absolute mess
this is
well look we want to see a sensible
pragmatic outcome to this
when we signed up to the protocol it was
always envisaged that
there would be hard edges that needed to
be um
shaved off and ironed out in the weeks
ahead and in fact the protocol
committed both sides to using best
endeavors
to sort out these sorts of things and
that's exactly what we want we we've put
forward some solutions
to the eu we hope that they will come to
the table today
as you say maracovich the eu's uh
interlocutor is meeting with lord frost
and we want to try to sort this out
because it can't be right
that a supermarket in northern ireland
can't have access to the same goods as
one
in wales scotland or england and a
sausage can't travel from
bangor in wales to bangor in northern
ireland we must be able to sort that out
indulge me and listen to what michael
gove had to say about it
we need to make sure that the the
sausages that our supermarket chains
provide to citizens in northern ireland
can continue to flow
we've secured that agreement with the
commission and that means that some of
the disruption
which people feared might occur after
the end of the transition period
won't occur well michael gove was
absolutely right i don't think
either side when we signed up to the
protocol envisaged that the eu would
uh interpret it in such a rigid
and unpragmatic way and we're asking
them to show some
common sense and enable something as
simple as
some chilled meats like a sausage to
travel from
gb to northern ireland because the
protocol was always
about ensuring the free flow of goods
between gb and northern ireland
as it was between northern ireland and
the european union
and i hope that we can sort those out
because there are also things even more
important
than sausages at stake here for example
medicines
it really would be absurd if a cancer
drug
struggled to be um dispatched
from the mainland of the united kingdom
to northern ireland
and we need to sort this out now so it's
the eu's fault for sticking to the
letter of the agreement
well the protocol itself envisaged that
there would be
sensible pragmatic discussions entered
into
in good faith and that it would evolve
with time and to some extent that's
happened we've actually made
a lot of progress on a number of fronts
but on this front
there now needs to be a resolution and i
hope these discussions today will
take that forwards um although you were
told by three former prime ministers
um and indeed the cbi that it would be
much more complicated
and um we were told by the prime
minister it was an overready deal
we have until the end of june to sort
this out um if the uk
unilaterally extends that grace period
which we have done on other aspects of
this
agreement then uh we're hearing from the
eu this morning that they
will retaliate strongly with legal
action
in their words how seriously should the
british government take that threat
well that we want to work in good faith
with our european friends and neighbors
we don't want to get into
legal action and it would be absurd if
there were legal cases
over whether a sausage manufactured in
birmingham
could be uh exported to be sold in
sainsbury's
in belfast that that doesn't make sense
that is not a good use of
the time of either country so i hope
that common sense will prevail
and the discussions that are going to
happen later today the first meeting of
this new council
will be the opportunity to break the
deadlock or at least
to move in the right direction yeah
fantastic alliteration but the eu will
say yeah whatever we are going to
threaten you with legal action meantime
the other side of the pond they're
saying
unless you sort out this deal there is
no us uk trade deal
well i think if you in respect of the uk
and the united states our interests are
aligned here
both countries have an unshakable
commitment to the good friday
agreement and that's what we want to
preserve
and support here the good friday
agreement was clear
that northern ireland is part of the
united kingdom for as long as
its residents want to be so and that
trade should flow
freely between uh the two nations and
that's what we want to see preserved and
so i think
uh president biden and boris johnson
will be entirely aligned
in their position we want a sensible
outcome to this
which preserves the position of northern
ireland within the united kingdom
and if you think about it it would be
ridiculous
for a u.s president to even consider
that something grown in alabama
couldn't be moved across the state
border to a neighboring state or a
medicine
produced in california couldn't be flown
to
be jabbed into the arm of somebody in
new york so
i think the president and others will
see the good sense of the british
position
and hopefully all the parties will come
to a resolution as quickly as we can
whose fault is it that there's a border
in the irish sea
well we have signed up to a protocol
which enabled northern ireland quite
rightly
to remain within the same customs
territory of the united kingdom
and that's the simple principle that
we're trying to enforce in okay
we're out of time everybody's rushing me
but i just wanted to ask you very
quickly about time swarms tell me about
it
yeah we just wanted to say a big thank
you to the people of cornwall
for hosting the g7 it's going to be a
fantastic
event the first meeting of the leaders
of the big western open societies
for almost two years and cornwall and
cornish people cornish police
have got huge efforts to stage this
event which i think will be a brilliant
one
and so today the prime minister is
announcing a series
of town deals to support communities
like saint ives like
penzance like truro so that they can
have transformative investments in
local infrastructure in culture in green
infrastructure cycle lanes and pathways
along the coast really important things
which will help to
build back better that beautiful part of
the country you're upbeat this morning
aren't you holidaying at home this year
are you
i think so yeah i might i might even go
to cornwall oh there we go it's lovely
to see you thank you for joining me
thanks